Tại bồi lễ công bố chiên trình gẹt thật chính luật tổ quốc trong tiêm,
đồng chiếc lẽ quốc mình, quý vien trung ơn đàn, tổng biên tập báo nhân dần,
phó trường văn tuyên giáo và dân vận trung ơn,
chùi tịch hội nhà báo Việt Nam cho biết,
tính đến thời điểm hiện tại,
nhiều vẽ vào cộng của chiên trình đã được dạo bán trên nhiều nhóm,
chúng tôi khẳng định,
hiện chưa có vẽ nào được đưa dàng ngoài thiệt trường.
Chúng tôi khuyến nghĩ người dân không nên bỏ tiện mua vẽ,
mời điều này sẽ làm cho những lối tượng trục lời được hưởng lời.
Báo nhân dần đã có công văn người lực lượng công an
phối hợp xử lý các lối tượng vốn bán vẽ ra,
chục lời từ trường trình này,
tổng biệt tập báo nhân dần lê quốc mình khẳng định.
Chứ đó, trong sáng ngày 1 tháng tắm,
báo nhân dần đã làm việc với các bàn sở ngày 1 tháng phố hà nội,
các lực lợp chức năng đề bảo đảm về anh nền,
sau thơm, e-tế, cho quá trình tổ chức trường trình diễn ra an toàn.
Chứ trình nghệ thuật chính luật tổ quốc trong tiêm
là sự kiện phân hóa chính trị,
cho mình tảm bây năm tích mặt tháng tắm,
và có khánh nước cộng hòa xã hội chủ nghĩa Việt Nam.
Trương trình dự kiến thu hút hàng trục nghiên khán giả trực tiếp tại sinh vận động
quốc gia Mỹ định, cùng hàng trường người theo giói qua sống trình,
và các nền tảng mặt xã hội.